a crimp top offers tight seal and
minimizes evaporation therefore is ideal
for gc applications the cons of a crimp
top are they require a crimper manual or
an electronic and they take more effort
and time a screw top requires no special
tools to use and still forms an
excellent seal for your application it
requires less effort to seal and its
most popular option for hplc
applications now the cons are that they
don't prevent evaporation as well as
their crimp top counterpart and scrub
tops have two numbers such as 8 to 425
with the first number to verify the
diameter in millimeters and the second
number to identify the thread size to
ensure compatibility with your vial a
snap top is the most convenient and the
fastest to use because no tools are
required to use it the cons or they are
not as secure as the screw or crimp top
caps because you got to just pop it on
there and it could just pop right off
and they are also typically used for
hplc and lcms applications now as far as
the color of the vials you use amber
vials when your application is light
sensitive otherwise the clear vials work
just fine